Every Saturday night it's movie night,
and there's no movie night that's complete without a good
selection of snacks.
So I started by making some cookies and cream ice cream.
Combine some milk and sugar with some vanilla and heavy cream
before putting it in my ice cream Turner to turn.
It reached soft serve consistency,
I added in my cookies,
let that go until everything was incorporated.
I don't know what it is about cookies and cream ice cream.
It's so good to me right now.
Pop that in the freezer to chill
while I got started on making some pretzel dough.
He loves pretzel bites, so I made these for him,
combined all of my ingredients,
and then kneaded the dough for letting it rise for about 30 minutes.
In the meantime,
I got started on making some gummy worms,
so I blended up some strawberries and raspberries.
In the meantime,
I heated up some apple juice and gelatin in my pot
until it was all dissolved
for combining the two
and then spooning it into my mold.
I let these set in the fridge while I worked on my pretzel dough.
After about 30 minutes,
I cut it up in six pieces and rolled those out into little ropes.
Once I did that with all of my six pieces,
I cut them up into smaller bite size pieces.
They don't all have to be perfect,
and I dropped them in some boiling water with some baking soda.
Before pulling them out,
salting them, and then baking them until they were golden brown.
All those were cooling off.
I got my gummy worms out of the fridge.
I wanted them to be slightly sour,
so I sprinkled them with some citric acid
and then moved on to the last thing I was gonna make
with some popcorn.
No movie night is complete without a big bowl of buttered popcorn.
Drizzled it with melted butter and some flaky sea salt
before I pulled my ice cream out and served us up
a bowl of that as well.
At this point
I was so ready to go watch the movie and eat all of the snacks.